so let me have shout the next couple of
weeks for you first up we're gonna get
Oddworld new n tasty then before July is
out we'll have the loss of a spring
mustard but what do they have in common
well almost nothing
you've got the heartfelt human story of
the Apocalypse and the story about a
creature called the medic on however
they are both games that have been
remade
well technically once classified as a
remake and the other is a green monster
while remakes are certainly not always
spectacular or even popular there are
some exceptional ones like Sid Meier's
pirates but at my all-time favorites as
well as the horrifying Fatal Frame 2 we
edition and Metal Gear Solid in the Twin
Snakes then there are the four games
that actually made it into my video so
I'll move on to them I'm not sure how
much you guys remember about my rant or
from my deep-seated feelings for Age of
Empires but it can basically be summed
up into the fact that I love that
franchise also apparently do a lot of
you since just last year interim phase
two got its own HD remake upon its
release there was some contention over
whether the unchanged textures sound
effects and gameplay of the remake from
the 1999 game were a good or a bad move
personally I have a huge fondness for
the original nostalgia inducing voice
clips and sounds when a building was
completed or a villager was spawned
trust me you definitely know that one
what was worked upon for the remaster
was the fact that the game runs very
well on modern pcs where it didn't
before and since it mosey over to steam
the game is now compatible with the mod
felt workshop and includes an exclusive
second expansion pack the online
multiplayer has been improved which has
spawned an active community and it's
still unapologetically old school if
pouring hours into campaigns and slow
paced realtime strategy game play was
never your gem then maybe leave this one
day but Age of Empires 2 is still an old
school strategy classic
next up is the game that also happens to
top my list of very best games
soundtracks we may not have been given
half-life 3 but we got the best
consolation prize in the cereal box
Black Mesa built in a source engine
black mesa is technically a mod but
distributed on Steam thanks to fan
attention through Steam greenlight the
game is a concoction by crowbar
collective who totally remade 1998 soft
life with more varied environments and
more challenging and realistic gameplay
thanks to sources physics engine this
impeccable remake has had real heart and
soul poured into it by the 40 person dev
team of volunteers and it really shows
Valve themselves said prior to release
that they were eager to play Black Mesa
as everybody else whether or not you've
played half-life recently or at all
Black Mesa is worth your time but just
keep in mind that the game's latest
stages are still in production for a
future release Sony have been touting
how awesome remakes are because they let
gamers experience masterpieces that they
may have previously missed out on
nowhere is this more true than the Eco
and Shadow of the Colossus collection on
ps3 team acre originally developed these
games for the ps2 where they suffered
from scarce availability in the case of
eco and near unplayable frame rates in
the case of Shadow of the Colossus for
the remasters the enchanting stories and
gameplay were left untouched but the
graphics were remastered for 1080p
displays the framerate issue was sorted
out and now you could play eco without
paying 150 bucks for it on eBay these
are brilliant examples of the well
chosen remaster where the process helps
fix and get the games into the hands of
a wider audience finally we've got the
fabulous Resident Evil remake for
Gamecube while those camera angles still
make me want to tear out my eyeballs and
with him as a hatch the remake was a
serious step in the right direction for
the 1996 survival horror game no game on
this list has an original quite as old
as this one having been developed for
the original Sony Playstation known
unofficially as Resident Evil
make the game improves hugely on the
graphics and sound and updated the
gameplay mechanics to incorporate
advancements from the newest sequels
while this means we miss out on the
campy live-action openings and millions
like the infamous chill sandwich line
it's totally worth it for the additional
areas improved pacing and completely
redone graphics as hilarious as the
jerky movements and terrible voice
acting of Chris no don't go Redfield and
Jill master of unlocking Valentine may
have been it's not worth your trouble to
wrestle with the dated flaws of the
original the remake is prettier more
responsive and importantly it's also
scarier while the GameCube version is
harder to find these days Resident Evil
remake was also ported to the Wii we
have a slightly different control system
being the only difference be sure to let
me know down in that comment box for
comments what your favorite video game
remake or remaster may be and in the
meantime since we won't be playing the
original resi anymore let's enjoy some
of these infamously terrible lines I'm
gonna go back and listen to the Black
Mesa soundtrack I will see you soon but
how about you Mary I have this thank you
I'll take this then that was too close
you were almost a Jill sandwich you're
right
it's a monster